he's at it again desperate Joe Biden
dusting off his Mega boogie man talking
points as problems pile up in his own
party and questions Mount if he's the
guy for 2024. Biden unveiling his new
budget that includes two trillion
dollars in tax hikes the president
laying out his plan and of course
picking a fight with those evil
Republicans
the Maggie Republicans want to take away
the law is that one of the things
they've announced they want to do away
with inflation reduction act Maggie
Republicans all voted to get rid of the
Affordable Care Act they voted to get
rid of it over 50 times since Barack
passed it Maggie Republicans are calling
for defunding the police department Mega
Republicans
you know they they don't want things
that particularly are going to help work
in families like Health Care education
Public Safety which can erase cost on
folks
look Maggie Republicans also refused to
raise a single penny in new taxes on the
wealthiest people
but Republicans may be the least of his
problems progressives in the Democratic
party are becoming a major thorn in
Joe's side they are slamming the
president on crime and immigration first
Biden sided with Republicans to block
that crazy Washington D.C insane soft on
crime Bill liberals who wanted to fund
the police are Furious Republicans are
taking advantage of the split
173 house Democrats voted to support
reduced sentences for violent crimes so
crazy even President Biden won't support
the Anarchy what's next defund the
police
Biden is also getting slammed for
considering a policy that would detain
migrant families at the border and it
hears AP with the kicker quote Biden's
re-election bid facing resistance from
some Democrats okay Jesse I absolutely
have to start with those Maga
Republicans they want to take away the
law they want to defund the police you
know in addition to being evil they
really want to they want to destroy your
life is this working for him
um
I don't know they poll tested Maga so
they're going with it but I'm bored
already talking about the budget
this is happening every single year so
the Democrats come in and they say we're
going to raise taxes on the rich
and the Republicans come in and say
you're not going to raise taxes on the
rich and then neither side cuts spending
and then the debt blows up
it happens every single time the left
says you don't care about poor people
you don't care about minorities and the
right says you guys don't care about the
budget and nothing ever happens and
we're going to play the same game and
he's going to propose something about
tax hikes and the Republicans have the
house so that's not happening and the
Republicans aren't going to cut defense
spending and the Republicans aren't
going to cut Medicaid or Medicare or
social security so you got to cut
discretionary and then they can't cut
discretionary because every time you
kind of cut discretionary they get
accused of being heartless soulless
scrooges and then the Democrats they're
not going to cut taxes they want to
raise taxes but they can't cut them
because they don't have the house so
this is just it's BS and I'm sick of it
Biden is smarter than I'm giving them
credit for because all of a sudden after
the midterms he's tacking back to the
center on crime and immigration and the
left's all mad at them but it doesn't
matter because the left hates them only
like 30 percent of the democratic party
wants them to even run for reelection
but that's all they have because without
him they have Kamala and mayor Pete and
that's a disaster you know Harold the
truth is that that Biden is kind of in a
tough spot now because now he's saying
you know that that it's the Republicans
who want to defund the police which is
so ridiculous I don't even want to ask
you about that but the idea that now he
was he was against the DC area reducing
the uh uh crime limits at terms and
that's going to make the progressives
upset he has to walk two lines here you
know I don't think so first of all I'm
very happy to be back around this table
yeah it's been a while so it's good to
see everybody and I'll be thinking about
you guys
um
the thing that Jesse said I think is
most interesting I want to answer your
point there's nobody running against him
but Marianne Williamson so when we talk
about resistance uh until someone else
gets in the race you'll hear people talk
you'll always hear people talk you got a
Republican primary where you have a
bunch of people talking about running a
few people in the race already if not
two so this is what happens in politics
but Jesse's right the moment we're at
right now with the debt ceiling there's
a huge fight about whether we should try
to try to negotiate Republicans to try
to negotiate make Democrats negotiate
the tame spinning to reduce spending to
increase the debt ceiling we should
increase the debt selling but this is
the fight we ought to have right now
because the debt selling that money has
already been spent Democrats and
Republicans ought to get down to the to
the real business of figuring out if
you're going to cut spending either for
mandatory spending or the non-mandatory
spending or discretionary or the
non-discretionary it'll be interesting
to see if they have the courage to do
that put the glazing over but but we're
in a as I'm saying you're right but
we're in a political season now so
you're going to hear Democrats say
certain things Republicans say certain
things President Biden is making it
clear he's for fighting crime he's not
for defunding the police he's for
funding the military he's for investing
in manufacturing and infrastructure it
will be interesting to see how
Republicans answer that I hope they have
robust and serious answers because
because the country needs it the only
way we're going to avoid this debt
selling debate which is a silly debate
like we're having right now is for the
debate to happen right now for
compromises to be made and for everyone
one to understand you can't reduce the
debt by just raising taxes as Democrats
some want to do and you can't just
reduce the debt by reducing spending as
some Republicans want to do it's going
to take a a coordinated effort the first
thing I would do if I was Republicans
make the Democrats take all that unused
coveted money and make put half of it
towards deficit reduction and half of it
towards either military spending or and
and or reducing the Medicare and Social
Security deficits that we have that's
how I would start all right go ahead
Sandra uh you know what else President
Biden is for imposing more spending
in a moment of Sky High record inflation
we got here because of big government
spending I mean think about the
remarkable moment that that was today
the president goes out and demonizes the
rich says they need to pay their fair
share says he's going to raise the rate
that corporate the corporations are
paying their corporate tax rates going
to go up so he's going to tax everybody
increase revenues when revenues aren't
the problem spending is the problem so
think about that and who is he running
against it looks like he's running
against members of his own party this
that Jesse just mentioned it the
number's 37 percent the Associated Press
says just 37 percent of Democrats
Nationwide want him to seek a second
term that's down from 52 percent that
wanted to run for reelection just before
the midterm elections so there is a big
drop in in population favorability you
know what you understand my point but if
we impose more spending during this time
of Sky High inflation you're going to be
in a much different economic situation
just even a few weeks months down the
road and that is going to put but
Democrats in great Peril if people are
still paying these sky high prices well
there's no question and they're going to
see that kind of thing in the
supermarket at the gas everywhere but
you know Greg Biden came in as a
moderate he said it was a moderate and
then we've got Bernie Sanders saying
he's the most Progressive president in
history and the truth is that he's
trying to dance a line you know I'm and
now I'm glad that he's changing if he
wants to fight crime but is it going to
win for him well he is the most
Progressive president in history and he
did perform as a moderate during the
election so he did both right he it's
called lying and it's good that he's
sided with the Republicans finally with
crime maybe some of them are coming to
their senses but it's because it's where
they live right their policies are
directly consequential because it's in
DC that's where they live right so why
can't this be done in other cities
because it doesn't affect them and this
is again another example where they
change the way they view things things
because now they're the ones that who
could be the victims especially when the
congresswoman was was victimized months
ago
um in terms of the budget I think we
have to stop calling it a budget right
it's identifying as a budget but when
you get its clothes off it's not okay
what is it it cannot be considered it's
a boat without a bottom it's technically
not a boat if there's no bottom and
there is no bottom to the budget How can
there be an achievement how can you
boast about getting a budget together
when there are no restrictions to what
you budget when you haven't a lot of
when you haven't said okay we have this
sum of money and these are the things we
want to pay for which is what every
person does at home we just can't print
money yeah we just can't remember and
then and so it has it's amazing it's
just amazing to me that we pretend that
this is an achievement oh look at this
look look at the job we did no you
didn't do anything you just went through
and picked all the stuff you wanted and
then you come up with a number with
these like these numerological chemists
that are coming up with this stuff but
they just you know this is not a budget
there's no sum of money that you then
allocate to different purposes so it's
not a skill either to come up with this
it's all a joke and the worst thing
about it is when you see people pretend
like it is an achievement when all
they're doing is putting a gun to the
taxpayers you know head basically I mean
it's a figuratively but if you don't pay
your taxes you go to jail they take our
money and then they give it to the
constituents like they're Santa Claus
and they act like they did it it's worse
than joke stealing they're basically
stealing they're stealing people's hard
work and they're pretending pretending
that it's coming from them
that's very good go ahead I just wish
the Republicans would offer I agree with
you the Democrats this is not a serious
budget and because you can't you don't
have all this money but the Republicans
won't offer a counter they just say
what's bad I was in that place you got
an offer a counter and then let's debate
it out and whoever wins is going to win
well you know it's the president who's a
Democrat you know and I think it's
really his job uh can't miss see and I
cut you off right there I can't miss
interview tonight on Hannity at 9 00 PM
Eastern our colleague Benjamin Hall
sitting down with Sean to talk about his
new book saved been describing the
moment his car was hit by a missile in
Ukraine
we slow down an abandoned checkpoint and
I don't know where the first missile
came out of nowhere
and's about 30 feet in front of us
immediately Pierre shout to reverse the
car reverse the car
there were two ukrainians driving as
well and five of us in the car
got stuck we couldn't go back and Pierre
shouted get out of the car everyone get
out of the car and the next second the
second bomb hits right in front of the
left of the car
and that one I went black
more of Benjamin Hall's interview
tonight on Hannity hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now